وروسيا تضيف قوة الى قوة سلاحها
بينما تحاول امريكا تجميع
الارهابيين. الصين لا تخشى احد
واوكرانيا تحشد مليون جندي.
مرسوم للرئيس فلاديمير بوتين
بتسهيل اجراءات الحصول على
الروسي معتبرا انه الخيار الاكثر
ترجيحا. واضاف لومير يتعين علينا
الاستهلاك. عن زيارة بايدن للشرق
الاوسط. اوضح جيك سوليفن مستشار
نأخذ اذنا من احد لحماية امننا
القومي وسنواصل ملاحقة
ان اي تطبيع يعد ايجابيا مضيفا
دبلوماسيتنا مع السعودية تشمل
تستلم فعليا اطول غواصة في
العالم بالقرود ذات الاغراض
الجنسية الروسية لجميع
الاوكرانيين باعطاء جميع مواطني
تحرك روسي اخر نحو تعزيز الوجود
وفرض واقع جديد في اوكرانيا
التركي لن نؤجل عملياتنا
العسكرية في الشمال السوري ولن
الخاصة وهي من نوع قادرة على حمل
ست بدون طيار. وزير الدفاع
وتسهيل الاجراءات لهذا الغرض.
بعد طول انتظار البحرية الروسية
تحسين العلاقة بين اسرائيل
والمزيد من الدول العربية قائلا
دولة داعمة لاوكرانيا بتكلفة
قدرها نحو خمسة مليارات دولار
الاستعداد الان لمعركة التنظيم
والتقنين والتقشف وخفض
اليوم ايها السيسي تجاه التطبيع
مع اسرائيل بعد هذه التصريح
الاسرائيلية يا له من امر حزين!
انها محرقة هولوكوست لجنود
الى جانب الدعم السياسي
والاقتصادي والعتاد العسكري
احياء على ايدي جنود اسرائيليين
في معركة استمرت تلاتة ايام خلال
الان الهدنة في اليمن والعمل على
تحقيق الامن الغذائي في المنطقة.
حرب عام سبعة وستين هناك تواصل
الرئيس المصري السيسي مع رئيس
الامن الامريكي ان رغبة الادارة
الامريكية في تعزيز ما سماه مسار
الاقتصاد الفرنسي الى الاستعداد
مسبقا لقطع كلي لامدادات الغاز
وتنوي بريطانيا تدريب عشرة الاف
جندي اوكراني على اراضيها ضد
الوزراء الاسرائيلي لبيد وبحث
هذا الامر وطالب السيسي واسرائيل
روسيا باجمالي ثلاثين الفا منذ
الفين وخمسة عشر. دعا وزير
بانتظار الضربة القاضية لاسقاط
الرئيس الفرنسي عن السلطة.
الاجابة نعم هذا مؤكد ولكن فقط
لدى المقاومة الفلسطينية التي
ان تبدأ تحقيقا كاملا وشفافا
بشأن هذه القضية لكن ما هو رأيك
خيبة ثانية وضربة لماكرون بعد
نتائج الانتخابات التشريعية
الاشتراكية وشركة اوبر العالمية
للنقل وكشفت المزاعم حول وجود
استنادا الى ملفات مسربة اطلقت
عليه تسمية ملفات اوبر.
تساءلت صحيفة اليومية الاكثر
قراءة في المانيا بوتين سيغلق
الهولوكوست المصرية. صحف
اسرائيلية نشرت تقارير عن وجود
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون عندما
كان وزيرا في حكومة هولندا
مصريين في اسرائيل. الاحداث
والتطورات. بريطانيا ثاني اكبر
هذه الصفقة في احدث تحقيق اجرته
مؤسسات اخبارية دولية رائدة
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني في فحوى
كلامه قال ان القبة الحديدية
مقبرة جماعية داخل احدى الحدائق
العامة في لجنود مصريين تم حقهم
اخترقت هذه القبة عديد المرات.
صدمة ماكرون. ندد نواب فرنسيون
اوباما لكن تقف امامه العديد من
التحديات في مقدمتها مشكلة
الاوروبية لتغرق اوروبا في
المجهول وتراجع حساباتها. هناك
بلاده ليست بحاجة الى منظومة
القبة الحديدية الاسرائيلية ضد
اسرائيل. كان السفير الاوكراني
لدى اسرائيل قد قال ان كييف تريد
مليار متر مكعب سنويا. وبحجة
الصيانة قطعت موسكو شريان الطاقة
فيما وصف بالتناقض في المواقف.
قال وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان
فاشلة ولا توفر الحماية بنسبة
مئة بالمئة فهل هي كذلك حقا?
شراء نظام الدفاعات الجوية
الاسرائيلية القبة الحديدية لكن
صنبور الغاز لكن هل سيعيد فتحه
يوما ما? سلاح اسرائيلي فاشل.
منفرد ينقل الغاز الروسي الى
المانيا تمر عبره خمسة وخمسون
صواريخ وذلك على عكس تصريحات
ادلى بها سابقا سفير كييف في
معارضون بوجود صفقة سرية افصحت
عنها تقارير صحفية بين الرئيس
هذه المرة كرئيس بعد ان زارها
مرات عديدة كنائب للرئيس السابق
اوكرانيا الحق في تقديم طلب
الحصول على جنسية الاتحاد الروسي
دول اوروبا. فهل يكون ذلك سببا
لشق الصف الغربي? وقالت الشركة
وينتظر القارة العجوز شتاء قارس
بدون تدفئة او طاقة مع ارتفاع
تحالف امني شرق اوسطي يضم دول
الخليج ومصر والاردن لكن مع
المشغلة لخط انها اوقفت امدادات
الغاز الى اوروبا لاغراض الصيانة
الكونجرس فكان من اشد الداعمين
لها. بايدن يقول عندما كنت شابا
اسرائيل فهل يقبل العرب بذلك?
قطع شريان اوروبا. تخوض اوروبا
السنوية المتوقع ان تستمر لعشرة
ايام. ويصنف خط بانه اكبر خط
دولة في العالم ان تتوهم امكانية
فصل تايوان عن الصين وحث دول
يتساوى سعر الدولار امام عملة
اليورو لتستفيد امريكا وتتضرر
الطاقة بسبب الحرب الاوكرانية مع
تخطيط الرئيس الامريكي لانشاء
لا حاجة لتكون يهوديا كي تكون
صهيونيا. سيزور بايدن اسرائيل
في مجلس الشيوخ اذا كنت يهوديا
فساكون صهيونيا. ولكن انا صهيوني
حربا من نوع اخر وتدخل في شديد
مع بدء توقف امدادات الغاز
اخرى اعادت رسم الخطوط الحمر
وحذر وزير خارجية من ان اي دولة
القوى الكبرى. فمن يجرؤ على
مواجهة التنين الصيني. يا ترى
وبوتين يعزز وجوده في اوكرانيا
بهذا القرار. مليون جندي. تخطط
في العالم يجب الا تتوهم بفصل
التايوان عن الصين ملوح باعاصير
بايدن يعترف. زار جو بايدن
اسرائيل مرارا عندما كان في
حاد في اسعار الوقود والطاقة
لتسجل اسعارا تاريخية ولاول مرة
المقابل رأت واشنطن ان سبب
التوتر واللهجة المستفزة لبكين
جنوب شرق اسيا على ضرورة تجنب
استخدامها كقطع شطرنج من قبل
الروسي? الصين لا تمزح. رغم لقاء
وزيري الخارجية الصيني والامريكي
الفرنسيون يعتبرونها سرقة كبرى.
ويقول الناشطون ان صفقة اوبر هي
وانشطتها تجاه تايوان. وقال
وانجي انه لا ينبغي لاي قوة او
الى المليون. وما الذي سيحدث ان
وصل جيشك المليون يا سيد
اخذته موسكو فهل يكفي هؤلاء
الجنود وبحجة الصيانة? روسيا
اوليكسي. هل ستستطيع استعادة
الاراضي الاوكرانية من فم الدب
استرجاع جنوب البلاد من الروس
بحسب تصريح لوزير الدفاع
شرسة في مضيق تايوان اذا تم
التعرض لمبدأ الصين الواحدة. في
نووية تنضم الى البحري الروسية
يا لهذا الرعب العسكري. فما هو
تقطع شريان اوروبا. بريطانيا
تجاهر بمعاداة روسيا وتصبح ثاني
الهدف منها يا ترى? مليون جندي
اوكراني لمحاولة استعادة ما
العالم العربي. وهنا ينتقل للشرق
الاوسط كي ينهي ما بدأه ترامب.
صحيفة التايمز البريطانية قال
لدينا حوالي سبعمائة الف عنصر في
اكبر الداعمين لكييف. فرنسا تتجه
لخطة تقشف غير مسبوقة. بينما خرج
لتشكيل جيش من مليون جندي مسلحين
باسلحة مقدمة من الناتو بهدف
القوات المسلحة. وان ضفنا الحرس
الوطني والشرط وحرس الحدود نصل
في بالي تبقى لغة التهديدات
سائدة بين البلدين. الصين مرة
تسريب صادم طال الفرنسي. واخيرا
يعترف بايدن ويقولها للعلن ليصدم
فماذا ينوي بايدن فعله في حين
تكشف اسرائيل عن محرقة هولوكوست
مصرية تقشعر لها الابدان. فما هي
ردة فعل السيسي والشعب المصري.
الاوكراني اوليك سيرزنيكوف. وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني في مقابلة مع
هكذا تصف الحكومة الاوكرانية
السلاح الاسرائيلي. اطول غواصة
بكين واي دولة ستفعل ذلك ستتسبب
بعواصف عسكرية عاتية. هكذا قالت
بكين فهل تجرؤ اي دولة في العالم
على ذلك؟ سلاح اسرائيلي فاشل
حلفائها من جديد. فمن ينجح
بمخططاته اولا اه.
لا ينبغي لاي دولة في العالم ان
تتوهم او تحلم بفصل تايوان عن